iron man was the spark for the mcu's
vast cast of characters but with the
twisted tangle of cosmic timelines did
you know he never met some of the other
heavy hitters keep watching to see the
five heroes iron man never met in the
mcu
tony may have met hank pym janet van
dyne and possibly even peggy carter when
he was younger that's plausible we saw
howard stark and hank working together
in both end game and the first ant-man
movie even though they had a falling out
with howard it's nice that hank and
janet attended tony's funeral in end
game in marvel comics janet's wasp and
tony's iron man were the co-founders of
the original avengers and even dated for
a while that's another story the only
ant-man character tony stark has met on
screen is scott lang first towards the
end of civil war and then later in
endgame after hope van dyne comes
through the portals and end game though
she doesn't really interact with iron
man it's a bummer they didn't get a
chance to meet especially since their
parents were co-workers then again scott
lang said and pym always said you never
can trust a stark toward tony in captain
america civil war leading tony to reply
who are you
if hope grew up hearing that too then
maybe she wasn't interested in becoming
pals
it's actually a plot point in infinity
war that tony stark doesn't know who
gamora is when he comes face to face
with peter quill in the guardian squad
by the time iron man spider-man and
doctor strange meet up with them in
infinity war gamora has already been
kidnapped by thanos she dies on vormir
shortly thereafter the new time
traveling 2014 version of gamora doesn't
really get to meet tony in end game
either this is kind of a shame for the
mcu especially considering that tony and
gamora absolutely hooked up in a comic
too one thing i've proven is that you
can count on me
to pleasure myself
black panther's sister shuri had a
really important role in infinity war
and got to be science bros with bruce
banner but iron man was in space at that
time it's possible that he hasn't met
okoye either but since she represented
wakanda at natasha's holographic zoom
meetings during the blip it's pretty
likely that the dora milage leader has
talked to tony via hologram at the very
least even though he retired to the
woods with pepper to raise morgan in end
game he wasn't totally off the grid
shuri was taken by thanos snap though so
we know she wasn't around
this does however raise an interesting
question has tony stark ever been to
wakanda he got close during the
vibranium heist in egypt ultron but we
have very little information on what he
knew about the secret nation and its
super science if t'challa and steve
rogers were harboring bucky barnes and
wakanda in the aftermath of civil war
then they probably weren't expecting mr
stark to visit anytime soon it sure
looks like he missed out on the world of
black panther entirely he never got to
experience all that advanced technology
or shuri's delightful personality
it would have been a real treat for fans
to listen to the two swap science
stories perhaps she could have even
shown him a more efficient way to make
an iron man suit when he was back in
that cave sometimes you gotta run before
you can walk
peter parker says to valkyrie when they
meet in the final battle against thanos
hey nice to meet you oh my god rocket
raccoon meets her new asgard when they
go to get thor an end game she becomes
good friends with the hulk during thor
ragnarok but unless tony took a trip to
norway we don't know about during the
five years that passed an end game iron
man hasn't actually met asgard's newest
monarch he also hasn't met lady siff the
only surviving member of thor's pals
either nor has he crossed paths with
darcy lewis or even future superhero
jane foster for that matter almost all
of the characters iron man hasn't met
are women are you noticing that too
thankfully representation in the marvel
cinematic universe is changing and
expanding with every new entry plus it's
probably not intentional that tony
didn't meet these women in the final
battle if you check out the deleted
scenes from end game there's a sequence
in which iron man is seen being honored
as he dies by wasp valkyrie and okoye
among others that didn't make it into
the film gamora opts out by the way hard
to say it counts but it's certainly
something to think about
make a move reindeer games
how the heck did iron man never meet
groot the sulking teenage tree is the
second guardian's character who hasn't
interacted with tony stark in infinity
war he was on a mission with thorin
rocket to forge a new hammer when tony
met the other guardians then groot
joined the wakanda fight with thor and
rocket and got snapped away by thanos
tony returned to earth an endgame and
met rocket raccoon who worked with him
on the time heist plan to retrieve the
infinity stones however groot didn't
show back up until the portals opened at
the end of the film missing tony
completely imagine the jokes iron man
would have made if he really stopped to
take notice of a sentient sapling
fighting beside him at least we'll
always have cap formally introducing
himself to groot in infinity war i am
true
i am steve rogers if you really want to
nitpick tony also never met howard the
duck who shows up in the end credit
sequence of guardians of the galaxy but
maybe that's for the best we're pretty
sure tony's head would explode coming up
with a whole bunch of nicknames for the
talking duck even the most ambitious
crossover event in history couldn't get
to everyone check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the mcu are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]